on the mount today for the tribe it's
right-hander mike clevenger now solaire
who's had the most success against
clevenger eight hits in 16 times up a
sizzling 500 batting average
the pitch swung on hit high in the air
deep to left field that's a way back and
that ball is gone
home run jorge solaire the american
league
champion in home runs last year has
number one in 2020.
[Applause]
salvador perez struck out three times in
last night's ball game as he went one
for four
and that ball is cranked to deep left
center field solaire and salvador perez
go back to back and salvi puts it up on
a tarp
in the left center bleachers
[Applause]
go ahead salvi
oh yeah rock his world and give give
that brady singer some breathing room
right there early that's huge on the
mound making his major league debut
right-hander brady singer
indians first baseman carlos santana
one of four consecutive switch hitters
at the top of terry francona's lineup
now the o2 to santana swung on drill
deep left field gordon going back on the
track near the wall makes the catch just
as he got near the wall and so brady
singer has a 15 pitch first inning keeps
the indians off the board
from mio reyes d.h hitting fifth
the one-two pitch swung on and missed oh
he threw a nasty breaking ball in the
outside corner that had reyes looking
bad on that swing and there's singer's
first big league strikeout as he gets
friend mia reyes
jorge soler will stand in
the 2-2 swing and a miss got him on a
breaking ball down and away and out of
the strike zone and clevenger able to
get out of it with his second strikeout
as he gets the dangerous solaire
the indians have runners had first and
second one out in the third
royals up 2-0 and jose ramirez the
batter walked his first time up
singer checks second comes to the plate
and ramirez broken back ground ball in
the hole and into right field of base
hit zimmer will try to score the throw
will go to third in with a slide and the
ball popped away from franco and that
got hernandez in safely into scores
zimmer and an rbi single by jose ramirez
and the indians cut the lead in half
trailing 2-1
and carlos santana who flied out to the
wall and left to the plate
singer's 2-2 offering to santana
gets away and here comes hernandez the
flip it will not be in time the indians
have tied the game jose ramirez goes
down to second on the play
singer checks the runner at second now
the pitch and a swing and a ground ball
to the right side first baseman playing
behind the bag mcgroom has it he was
positioned perfectly takes it to the bag
himself that ends the inning jose
ramirez steps in he's walked
and came through with an rbi single back
in the third
brady
with the pitch
tried to check his swing but he went
past and that is a strikeout seven
strikeouts for brady singer in his major
league debut
he heads to the sixth inning of play
with the royals and indians tied at two
let's see if salvi can maybe hit a
second home run today
between third and short
lindor with a long throw got him
unbelievable play by francisco lindor
and a great stretch on the back end by
carlos santana and now you turn the
lineup over to the top of the order with
merrifield who led the american league
in hits last year with 206
2-2 ball game in the eighth whitcrin's
pitch is swung on hit pretty well to
center racing back mercado still
backtrack reaches out makes the catch
brushes up against the wall to the right
of center whirls the throw back in and
starling scampers back to first
oscar mercado is the batter
three ground outs today right-hander
against right-hander come set
the one-two pitch
got him and it was the slider buried in
the dirt and salvi did a great job
cupping his body keeping it in front of
him it only rolled about five feet away
so a critical second out here in the
bottom of the ninth inning and the bases
stay loaded with two down
and catcher roberto perez has struck out
three times today
now he's ready
the 3-2 pitch
swung on and missed he struck him out
and perez is done the cleveland indians
leave the bases loaded we head to the
10th inning of play tied at two
and this will be franco who has power he
doesn't have a hit this year yet he's
over three
today oh for seven so far the runner at
third is phillips one one defranco is
driven deep to center field mercano
going back he catches it right as he
gets to the warning track more than deep
enough to allow brett phillips to score
from third and the royals take a 3-2
lead here in the 10th inning lindor won
for four today he's never faced holland
until now the runners go and lindor
strikes out
and greg holland picks up his first save
in five seasons with the royals